Traduttore: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Andrea Giglio
Oggi vi volevo parlare
di una persona speciale: Aaron Swartz.
Quando gli hanno dedicato un documentario
l'anno scorso, nel 2014,
l'hanno intitolato:
"The Internet's Own Boy",
il pupillo di Internet.
È molto difficile mettere Aaron
in categorie precise.
È stato un attivista, un programmatore,
un ricercatore.
Io aggiungerei un hacker, in senso buono,
e un intellettuale, uno scrittore.
È più semplice però fare una lista,
per quanto tecnica, di progetti
a cui lui ha collaborato,
sono decine e decine.
Aaron a 14 anni era nel gruppo
che scrisse l’RSS.
Magari voi non dice molto ma era ubiquo
nella blogosfera fino a 10 anni fa.
E costruì a 15 anni le Creative
Commons, occupandosi della parte tecnica.
Oggi le Creative Commons sono circa
in un miliardo di contenuti.
Sono delle licenze libere
che rendono il copyright
più flessibile e aperto.
Sono, per esempio,
la licenza di Wikipedia.
Aaron a vent'anni diventa
un piccolo start-upper.
Fonda una cosa chiamata Reddit.
Diventa milionario da un giorno all'altro.
Però ad Aaron sinceramente non fregava
tanto dei soldi o della fama.
Continua a fare quello
che ha sempre fatto:
costruire un’Internet libera,
aperta e collaborativa.
Collabora con Internet Archive
e Open Library, due biblioteche digitali
che stanno letteralmente salvando il web
e preservando terabyte e terabyte
di Internet
che altrimenti andrebbe perduto,
sono archivi di memoria digitale.
Diventa uno dei protagonisti
della lotta contro SOPA,
una legge bavaglio,
che qualche anno fa costrinse
persino Wikipedia a fare sciopero,
ad andare in black-out
perché avrebbe limitato enormemente
la libertà di espressione su Internet.
Quello che in Aaron assolutamente colpisce
è una straordinaria, formidabile
e feroce curiosità.
Aaron, ce lo dice lui stesso nel suo blog,
era capace di leggere
fino a 150 libri all’anno.
Tutti i saggi: dall'economia,
alla teoria politica,
alla storia dell'educazione,
all’informatica.
Girava con “Il capitale” di Marx
sottobraccio a 16 anni.
Aaron - e questo ci racconta suo fratello
in un momento molto toccante
del documentario che dovete
assolutamente vedere -
aveva imparato ad imparare, prestissimo.
Ci racconta sua madre che,
a un certo punto, lei stava cucinando
e un Aaron, aveva due anni e mezzo
ed era seduto nel seggiolone,
le lesse l'avviso sul frigo,
che lei aveva appena
attaccato con le calamite.
Aaron, però, scopre una cosa importante.
Questa sete di conoscenza ha uno specchio,
ha un suo doppio:
cioè fame di conoscenza
diventa fame di condividere conoscenza,
perché la conoscenza
deve essere condivisa.
Se guardiamo ai progetti di Aaron vediamo
che sono tutti strumenti e tecnologie
per l'accesso all'informazione.
In Internet Archive preserva la memoria,
l’RSS permetteva ai blog
di sincronizzarsi,
le Creative Commons sono un copyright
e quindi rendono accessibile alle persone
il contenuto creativo.
L'accesso all'informazione nasce
da un concetto estremamente semplice
Ma fondamentale per quanto banale,
cioè che l'informazione è potere.
Informazione è potere,
che noi, basta pensarci,
in un secondo troviamo ovunque.
Troviamo nelle scuole, nelle biblioteche,
nell'università.
“Informazione è potere” lo diceva
don Milani, lo diceva anche la Montessori.
Cioè dare accesso
all'informazione alle persone,
vuol dire far compiere
un atto democratico.
La nostra democrazia letteralmente si basa
sul dare accesso all'apprendimento,
all'educazione.
Senza questo non c'è democrazia.
È un atto di empowerment,
Di abilitazione dell'altro.
Il fatto che Aaron arriva a questo,
da genio qual è,
dal suo retroterra culturale
che è quello dell’hacker.
L’hacker come costruttore,
non come distruttore.
Quando conosci il codice
e hai le competenze per leggerlo
puoi modificarlo, puoi renderlo tuo,
puoi fargli fare quello che vuoi.
Quindi spiegare il mondo diventa
una condizione necessaria
per piegare il mondo,
per renderlo malleabile,
per poterlo modificare.
Rendere il mondo
un posto migliore presuppone
un accesso a questa informazione.
E quindi se tutte le istituzioni
Sono sociali, sono fatte da persone,
quindi fondamentalmente sono cultura,
sono fatte di parole.
Tutto diventa hackerabile
nel momento in cui conosci il codice
e sai come si modifica.
Ma questa cosa non la fai da solo.
Se rendi il mondo Open Source, ad accesso
aperto, tutti potranno aggiustarlo.
Rendere il mondo un posto migliore
Non diventa un atto singolo di eroismo,
ma diventa un atto
di costruzione collettiva.
Circa nel 2011, Aaron si interessa
a questa cosa che si chiama “Open access”.
Un grande movimento per l'accesso libero
alla letteratura scientifica.
Il mondo della letteratura scientifica,
magari c'è qualche universitario in sala,
è un mondo assolutamente caotico
e controverso, contraddittorio.
Pochissimi grandi editori
hanno le chiavi del potere,
Rendendo scarso ciò che è scarso non è,
cioè l’informazione scientifica.
E Aaron si appassiona al tema,
scrive questa cosa che si chiama:
“Guerilla Open Access Manifesto”,
lo scrive tra l’altro qui in Italia.
La prima frase era:
“L’informazione è potere”.
Aaron scarica centinaia di migliaia
di articoli da un database accademico:
JSTOR.
Viene beccato.
L’FBI lo aveva “attenzionato”.
Un hacker di tale genio
non passa inosservato.
Capisce che è la sua opportunità
per fare di Aaron un esempio.
Vogliono dargli una condanna esemplare
Per mostrare a tutti gli hacker là fuori
che il mondo non si cambia
con un paio di righe di codice.
Aaron viene fatto oggetto di una vera
e propria persecuzione giudiziaria
Per aver scaricato centinaia di migliaia
di articoli da un database accademico,
e poteva farlo, però non in tale scala.
Gli vengono contestati atti
di pirateria informatica.
Rischia fino a 35 anni.
Spende milioni di dollari
in questa causa legale.
E viene equiparato ne più ne meno
che a un terrorista.
Due anni dopo il suo primo arresto,
Aaron si impicca in casa sua a New York.
Aveva 26 anni.
Il punto è che il potere lo sa
che l'informazione potere.
E se decidi di essere l’ingranaggio
che ferma il sistema,
questo ti schiaccerà con tutta la forza
combinata degli ingranaggi attorno a te.
È una cosa che abbiamo già visto
recentemente con Edward Snowden,
Chelsea Manning, Julian Assange.
Tutti i casi diversi eppure simili.
Gente che voleva dare accesso
all’informazione per quanto controversa.
Vorrei farvi vedere adesso un minuto
dall’ultima intervista di Aaron Swartz
pochi mesi prima di morire.
[I] Giusto per dare un seguito,
come ritieni stia andando la lotta?
[AS] Dipende da te.
[AZ] Mancano i sottotitoli,
adesso arrivano.
[AS] Sai, ci sono
due prospettive contrapposte:
Tutto va bene, Internet ha creato
una grande libertà e indipendenza
e tutto quello che verrà
sarà fantastico...
oppure tutto va male.
Internet ha creato enormi
mezzi di sorveglianza,
per spiarci e controllare
quello che diciamo.
Io penso che tutte e due
queste visioni siano vere.
Internet ha fatto entrambe le cose,
ed entrambe sono stupefacenti.
Quale vincerà nel lungo termine
dipende solo da noi.
Non ha senso dire:
‘Una va meglio dell’altra...',
perché sono entrambe vere.
Dipende da noi
quale deve essere enfatizzata
e da quale delle due vogliamo
trarre beneficio,
perché entrambe sono
e saranno sempre presenti.”
Aaron dice qui una cosa banale
quanto fondamentale.
Ci sono due prospettive polarizzate
Di Internet:
Internet è orribile,
è una piattaforma di spionaggio di massa.
Viene utilizzato per spiare,
per controllare, per opprimere.
E invece c’è un’altra prospettiva:
Internet è fantastico, libera,
un posto di totale libertà di espressione.
In realtà queste cose sono uguali,
sono vere entrambe,
sono sono cose che coesistono
allo stesso modo.
Internet è troppo complesso
per essere una cosa sola.
Aaron dice una cosa importante:
“It’s up to us”, dipende da noi
quello che vincerà, perchè Internet
sarà sempre questa cosa complicata.
Io volevo finire non con parole mie
perché non ne ho,
ma con parole di qualcuno più bravo.
“L’inferno dei viventi
non è qualcosa che sarà;
se ce ne uno, è quello che è già qui,
l'inferno che abitiamo tutti i giorni,
che formiamo stando insieme.
Due modi ci sono per non soffrire.
Il primo riesce facile molti:
accettare l'inferno e diventarne parte
fino al punto di non vederlo più.
Il secondo è rischioso ed esige attenzione
e apprendimento continui:
cercare e saper riconoscere chi e cosa,
in mezzo all'inferno, non è inferno,
e farlo durare, e dargli spazio.”
[Italo Calvino, Le città invisibili]
Grazie.
[Applausi]